firstly I laid on top of this quantitive
axes right so you've got neck
access your y-axis we've got the orange
hanging around the middle okay in order
to talk about any of this if it's sort
of coordinate set of axes it's going to
be useful to have well coordinates right
now for example let's call this guy up
here this point that we started with
woman I started with I'm going to give
you a date now being that these four
points third amazing to do with each
other right I don't have much to say all
this has to be the first one has been in
second or wherever right it really is a
red the point you can redraw a whole new
quadrilateral and be somewhere else
right in the one see you next year those
are somewhere else as well so I'm just
going to call this as general as I can
make it I think back to what we were
doing you court created divide their
lifetime P if you've got too many points
and you say I want to have a line
through those two points we put the
coordinates of those into one formula
what we call those points is usually
what do we need the coordinates we would
usually call them x1 y1 because we're
like I don't know it's a DX of Y that
you like and then you've got a second
one so instead of X on Y what you call
it x2 I do
okay so that's fine I've gotten halfway
around I guess I might as well continue
I do have four points after all again
they have nothing to do with each other
right so therefore I have to call it X 2
y 3 and X 4 y 4 ok so at least I've got
names of this thing then I have to think
how did we create that red tape again
how do we make it we create a bit points
in we've bisected every side of the
quadrilateral and then that gave us you
can wondered okay
now to bisect you find the midpoint will
you guys have to find the points don't
you now I'm going to give you one more
clue will give you one more clue which
is more a question than is even a deals
parallelogram
I like the original shape thank you
a parallelogram is a very special shape
paralleling a set needs of profit
problems which means if you want to
prove something is parallelogram you
actually lots of different ways to do it
what's the obvious way I mean the way
that stands out to you from the diagrams
that give D okay Grady is the most
obvious way if you can find these
gradients and these gradients if it is a
parallelogram they should be the same
right that will be one way to do it and
that's fine
you actually can totally do it that way
however one of the things that we'll try
to illustrate to you on the next little
somebody today is that one sometimes you
can do something one way that doesn't
mean that you should think again
parallelograms size a parallel or
opposite side darken what else do you
know about parallelogram what else do
you know yes oh yeah yeah okay diagonals
is interval here and this is a repeat a
should bisect each other now how would
you go about proving that using core
geometry I'll give you another couple of
fruits right officer science in
parallelograms right they've not just
parallel what else are they look at the
diagram they're equal I think so if you
found some distances that would be
another technique that you could use I'm
not saying you should which you care
right now we could keep going there are
lots of things about a parallelogram
that make it a parallelogram that if you
know are true you can say therefore ABCD
is a parallelogram have a think about
that see how far you get I'm going to
show you the way to I'm going to prove
it but as I sort of alluded to before
just as important as the way that I
prove it is the way that I choose not to
prove it illustrate what you guys do so
cool the part that I'm going to choose
through is actually when the date
mentions which is that all the
properties that I can think of for
proving in a parallelogram is relatively
the size of the diagonals bisect as
you'll see the Venus is a particularly
good way to go about it
not necessarily like it's a better
better proof as you see see
I think it actually a lot faster so
let's first get a picture on this and
one of the things you will discover very
quickly when you're having got these
questions is the picture it forms so
much of what you do during a good
picture takes time but the time it saves
you interests area in a question not
really knowing what it's talking about
is well worth the effort so if you
haven't already go ahead and draw lunch
for me the diagonals of this new
parallelogram or at least that's what we
think it is okay
now this point in here we want to show
that these diagonals meet at that point
and that they virtually bisect one
another that phrase is really important
that they mutually by taking each other
because there are other shapes where the
controller knows like that my fellow
bisects both ways so for example if you
drop yourself on the side of your page a
kite which is emphatically not a
parallelogram right you can see what are
the things about a client is that if you
look at the shorter diagonal here or at
least my claim into the shorter one
that's by check the thinner this in
focus bisected at right angles which is
kind of fitting but the other diagonals
see so I want you to prove that these
diagonals both bisect each other what
would be the way that I could do this
well let's rewind a little bit we said
that we want to find out the coil of
this or it will be useful to find at the
coordinates of this new parallelogram
u-shape and because I know the corner so
I've made the coordinates of all of the
original points it's actually very easy
to state what say this point is is this
dent a while on is x2 y2 all you have to
do is quote the midpoint formula and
tell me what quarter to this point
ah what are they
x1 plus x2 / to come up y1 plus y2 also
/ - you're just average infinity right
as wonderfully about is is because every
point that we've just placed on the
coordinate axes is in the same format it
doesn't take me much mental thought to
keep on going all the way around so for
example this guy down here will not be
x1 plus x2 it'll be x2 plus x3 same for
the Y's and you can go all the way
around and complete that in fact if you
haven't already why don't you go ahead
and add out along with you ok so now I
don't where all the vertices of my
so-called parallelogram apart how am I
going to show that these mutually bisect
each of these diagonals okay now
remember I said to you it's going to be
just as important for you to see the way
that I don't do this as well the moment
I do do it if two things mutually bisect
each other what that means is these
relate to the same and these two into
the same right these two links and these
two eights so when I think about like
saying that for this obvious way to show
for a double of each unit for the same
is well find it too late how would I do
that these chilling time pointing out
right now let's give a name shall we
let's call this a P Q R and s if you
want changed for the sake of
completeness you call your original
you can put your original shape ABCD so
one of the names of the diagonals
I've got P R and Q s what did you get an
appropriate name for the place where
they're all supposed to be Trey's a
little right let's make a good cool team
I probably wouldn't have called P
because that suggested order pqrst like
a pentagon I probably wouldn't call
something different like every could you
did the little